[Music]
hello
and welcome to google cloud i'm drishti
and i have michael with me
we are solution engineers for google
today we will show you a demo that
depicts one way to modernize your legacy
java applications
using anthous on google cloud
java is the most common runtime when it
comes to deploying applications in
production environments
consequently it comes as no surprise
that most companies are
intent on protecting their past
strategic investments in java
including retaining internal java
developer expertise
there are hundreds and thousands of
existing enterprise java applications
most of them are actively maintained but
are not being actively developed
patching and maintenance of the
application and its infrastructure
continues to grow
the only way left to modernize these
applications
is to rewrite them which is tremendously
time consuming
at google cloud we have identified few
different solutions
to address the pain points and today we
will be showing a demo
of option number one modernize with
containerization
when you onboard java application to
container
with antholos and automate development
process with a software pipeline
you see a 37 tco savings instantly
furthermore automating testing and
refactoring the application
one starts to see an additional 78
in tco savings first let me provide you
with a few anecdotes so that the demo
resonates better with you
hipster shop is a company who has modern
online boutique website
running on google cloud they also
maintain an on-premise vmware
environment that is primarily hosting
legacy applications
most of which are no longer getting new
features and are simply
keep the lights on apps one such
application is the legacy crm java app
which they would like to modernize and
run on google cloud
hipster shop's google cloud environment
they have anthos clusters running on
google kubernetes engine
to host their modern applications they
utilize anthos configuration management
to keep common kubernetes configuration
and policies in sync
and up to date across the clusters the
source of truth for these config files
and policies
must reside in a git repo so hipster
shop leverages their own instance of
gitlab
running on gke they also use antho
service mesh
on their production clusters to collect
mesh telemetry
defined service level objectives and
secure communications across the
microservices that make up their
applications
in their on-prem vmware environment
hipster shop uses
vcenter server appliance installed on an
esxi
host to manage their inventory of
virtual machines
to begin modernizing the apps running on
these vms
hipster shops operators needed to set up
migrate for anthos to snapshot their vms
and generate their container images
the legacy crm java application is
deployed on a weblogic application
server
they also installed the weblogic server
kubernetes operator
on their anthos cluster to automate the
deployment and management of a weblogic
environment
running on kubernetes let me now show
you these components running live in
vmware and google cloud platform
hipster shop's vmware esxi host is
running on an on-premise bare-metal
machine
they manage and configure their vm
inventory through the vcenter server
appliance
the legacy crm java application that
hipster shop's operators will modernize
is running on red hat enterprise linux
vm that you see here
weblogic server is installed on the
virtual machine and provides the
weblogic application server that the
legacy crm application runs on here's
the front end of the hipster shop's
legacy crm java application
the application follows standard java
enterprise edition design principles
for example the domain and the facade
layers of the application utilize java
spring framework
and the java messaging service and the
presentation layers
use java server pages and faces
let me now show you hipster shop's
modern cloud infrastructure running on
google cloud platform
hipster shop's modern online boutique is
running on two anthos kubernetes
clusters
staging for testing and production these
clusters will also host the legacy crm
application
after the migration from vmware both of
these clusters
run on google kubernetes engine but with
anthos
hipster shop can have clusters running
across multiple cloud and on-prem
environments such as aws or vmware and
they will be viewed and managed from the
google cloud console
there is also a separate migrate for
anthos processing cluster that will run
the migration of the java application
from vmware without having to worry
about production applications being
affected
finally you will see hipster shop's
gitlab cluster running on gke
to host their anthous configuration
management repo
i will now pass it off to michael who
will play the role of
a hipster shops operator and will
modernize the legacy crm java
application
using google cloud's anthoc solution
thanks drishi i will first use
migrateforanthos to containerize the
hipster shop legacy crm application
so that it can be deployed to the anthos
clusters running on google kubernetes
engine
migrate for anthos uses the mig ctl
command line interface
to define the source and the destination
of the migration
and to kick off the migration process as
you can see here i have already set up
the vmware environment as the source of
the migration
to begin the migration of the legacy crm
application
i first create a migration plan using
the mig ctl command line interface
the migration plan will provide details
such as the vmware virtual machine that
hosts the source application
and where the new containerized images
from the migration will be stored
migrate for anthos is able to determine
what files from the virtual machine are
needed to produce a containerized image
of the source application
i only need it to specify the
directories that should not be included
in the migration
and the directories that contain data
that should be persisted to a persistent
volume
when i finish running this migration
plan on the mygratefuranthose processing
cluster
a set of artifacts are automatically
generated for me
and stored in a google cloud storage
bucket i can download these artifacts to
my cloud shell or local machine
these artifacts include a docker file to
update my source application's container
image
a persistent volume on a google cloud
persistent disk
that contains my source application's
data and a kubernetes manifest
that i will use to deploy my application
to a kubernetes cluster
in the dockerfile artifact i can see
that the migrate for anthos runtime
is used as the base image and it's
combined with a non-runnable base image
that contains
a replica of the source virtual machine
i can also make
updates to packages in the container and
can upgrade the migrate for anthos
runtime in the future for new releases
or bug fixes
i can make changes to this docker file
as i would to any other docker file
i make the changes rebuild the image and
push to a container registry
such as google cloud's private container
registry in the kubernetes manifest file
that was generated for my application
i have a stateful set with hipster
shop's legacy crm container image
specified in the image field
the weblogic admin console and the
hipster shop legacy crm are exposed on
port 7001
so i also expose that port on the source
applications container
a load balancer service is also defined
so that the application is accessible
from a browser
finally there is a persistent volume
that specifies the google cloud
persistent disk
which contains the legacy crm migrated
data
and a persistent volume claim that
mounts that volume to the kubernetes
container
to deploy the hipster shop legacy crm
application
i apply the kubernetes manifest file to
my staging anthos cluster
where i will be able to test the
application's functionality before
releasing the application in production
once the deployment is complete i can
navigate to my kubernetes services
to find the endpoint for my hipster shop
legacy crm
application
[Music]
it seems like there is something
preventing the application from loading
luckily i know exactly what the issue is
by default all new applications on the
staging and production clusters have a
kubernetes network policy
that prevents external traffic from
reaching the container
this network policy is defined in a
kubernetes configuration file that is
stored in hipster shop's anthos config
management repository
as drishi explained earlier hipster shop
is using their own instance of gitlab
running on gke to host their anthous
config management repository
this repository contains kubernetes
configuration and policy files
that are automatically applied to
hipster shop's staging and production
clusters
and the configurations and policies are
kept in sync with this
source of truth repository to prevent
any unwarranted deletions or changes
the anthos config management repository
is structured in a way that allows me to
apply
configuration and policies across all
clusters
at an individual cluster level or at a
namespace level if i go to the directory
for the namespace that contains the
hipster legacy crm application
i can open the networkpolicy.yaml
and i'll see the policy that is
currently preventing me from accessing
the hipster legacy
crm application
i will make a change to this
configuration file to allow
all external traffic to reach my
application
and i will commit my change to the
repository
i can now go check if my configuration
took effect by refreshing
great i can now access the hipster shop
legacy crm
only this time it's running on an
anthous kubernetes cluster
the network policy change that i made in
the anthous config management repository
was almost immediately synced across my
staging and production clusters
after testing the hipster legacy crm in
the staging environment
i can promote the application to
production to begin taking advantage of
the rich
feature set of antho service mesh antho
service mesh provides
traffic management observability and
secure communication
across all the services running on my
anthos clusters
from this single pane of glass i am able
to view the 10 micro services that make
up hipster shop's
modern online boutique website but i'm
also able to see the legacy crm that was
just migrated from vmware
antho service mesh automatically proxies
all requests between services
and collects a standard set metrics
without having to make any changes to
the application source code
i see those metrics displayed in this
table and i will see them across many of
the other
antho service mesh screens as these
metrics help
gauge the performance of my application
services
another helpful view in antho service
mesh is the topology view which again
shows the same services that are running
on hipster shop's anthos clusters
but in a graphical format that
highlights the inbound and outbound
connections of each service
and i can see here the hipster legacy
crm service that i just deployed
if i click on the service i will see the
set of standard performance metrics
displayed in the widget on the right
now as an operator my job requires that
i keep all of hips or shop services
running across staging and production
clusters at an optimal state
you might ask what is an optimal state
and the answer is that it really depends
each service is different there may be
some services where a slight degradation
and performance will negatively
impact the end user's experience while
other services
may not be as delicate and slight
performance changes will go unnoticed
with antho service mesh i have the
ability to set service level objectives
or slos for each service so that i can
proactively monitor
hipster shops applications health and
ensure that end users are not having a
negative experience
i have already set up an slo for hipster
shops legacy crm
application let's take a closer look at
how i define this objective
the metric i'm interested in monitoring
and maintaining for this service is
latency
or how long it takes the hipster shop
legacy crm service
to respond when it receives a request
next i specify my latency threshold
that is the maximum amount of latency
i'm willing to accept for my service to
be considered
at an optimal state i set the threshold
to be 20 milliseconds
i then set the time period i want to use
for evaluating the slo to be
a rolling one day period finally
i choose a performance goal with my goal
set to 90
i am saying that the hipster shop legacy
crm services latency
should be below the threshold of 20
milliseconds
90 of the day so that wraps up our java
application modernization demo with
anthos
in this demo you saw how a java spring
application was migrated off of a
virtual machine running on vmware
to an anthous kubernetes cluster running
on google cloud's kubernetes engine
you saw how a kubernetes network policy
or any other configuration or policy
file
can be synced across multiple clusters
in a matter of seconds using anthoconfig
management
and finally you saw how an operator can
use antho service mesh and the
observability metrics it provides to set
service level objectives on their
containerized services
thank you and we look forward to showing
you more application modernization tools
on google cloud in the future